welcome to this video I'm a bit late but
later i'm losing about 20 seconds
against Omega Z Z Omega it's that right
okay the Kings Indian let's go for age
three and okay I feel like playing a
assemble position with Queens off yeah
okay he's playing an interesting line
and rooks see one I think it's the way
to play this the ideas play c5 now turn
I think black black and flame c6 or
maybe even c5 is also possible
yeah this leads to a very complicated
game it takes on d5 now I go here now
this can can get very tricky one key
point is Sir f5 ok so hmm if I take his
playing eve 426
hmm
I can take only five efore d6 rook v6
Bishop c4 it's probably nonsense okay I
need to I need to get the King out of
them out of the way one way to play
knows f5 it's Holly I have studied this
ages ago f 585 efore Bishop b2 takes
Bishop f3 with two pawns for the for the
piece but i have c 585 very dangerous
passports at five I'm not sure if it is
this position but the idea the IDS size
is some stupid Khan is taking some time
so maybe considering this f5 okay yeah
okay here my hopes are connected with
the 33 against you with a possible
passer later and I'm nicely coordinated
the bishop on your form yeah okay is
there something better Jack probably not
it's always attacking b7 so there's some
some pressure cannot easily move the
bishop as they take on b7 okay let's not
not spend ages here I've got some time
advantage and I don't want to spoil it
so c 60 isn't this helping me probably
something like this is better night's
e46 looks like a good idea the knight on
f3 isn't doing so much it a detective
five but not see 46 looks a much much
more town much more powerful
mmm I didn't consider that at all hmm
still 96 0 is this is just looking good
and not doing much sometimes this
happens you come across a move that it's
making a nice impression but it's not
really doing much yeah yeah song bad but
now maybe I don't have anything better
than just just taken place e6 symptoms
it's possible
yeah it's still a passed pawn and bit
dangerous it's lots not so easy for
black to play and if you place Bishop c5
which would which looks like a normal
way to proceed c7 rg8 not not helping
Bishop c5 I always have this sacrificial
IDM yeah I can actually take your phone
take the six places seven
okay let's do that it should should be
some some nice edge in the end game
maybe not the absent best but it keeps
the pressure on if i'm not totally
mistaken him I'm not a porn up I
completely miscounted here i thought i'm
still a porn up but of course this isn't
the case at this is stupid yeah just
idiotic I thought I was a pawn up still
okay yeah this is of course no edge at
all I need to need to be a porn up to to
play for something here oh I just forgot
about that probably not not a big issue
yeah this was stupid it was just just a
somewhat better end game nothing
spectacular probably a draw but I can
take him I can take on g3 check
check-check know what an idiotic game
dang it is really a bad really bad I
mean not winning has already a bit
disappointing but losing its family bad
okay Mike resigns yeah i've talked about
giving a giving the game away and i was
just too too relaxed him not paying
attention at all i can i can play
basically anything look da don whatever
so yeah can't stuck in place though and
this is also better yeah and this I'm
five Brooks he said yeah I don't know
what was just just to irritate it after
it wasn't it wasn't a porn up so this
whole thing was just bad taking on e4
it's clear that white is just better
here I was Miss counting I thought I was
a pawn up at the end which is not the
case I should just cost not should just
he made the hip bleep late this I can
just play something like that and
continue with the pawn of course its
opposite colored bishop so it's not a
win or something but this is just white
pressing not clear if you can can
windows but why Tesla is pressing in
this position I just I just thought I'd
be born up and I'm not enough of course
I should never use it even with more
time on the clock but here it gets it
gets somewhat tricky already maybe mmmm
maybe if I take here spectrum
yeah this is somewhat better and I still
shouldn't lose it yeah just just a very
bad end game that I played him also this
shouldn't lose I mean this this should
lose check you look at this no I know I
care okay I need to do this now now get
get this pawn there's also also bit
critical yeah f your cos the completely
unnecessary to get get into the endgame
a good lesson how not to play oh thanks
for watching